Salut ! aujourd'hui je vais essayer de mentaliser quelqu'un de .très spéciale .
tres speciale parceque c'est mon chien
c'est vanille.je sais pas si je vais la mentaliser ou juste l'embrouiller avec mon tour de magie mais je tente un coup avec un os
tiens,ca c'est pour toi .hop.rire.c'est assez incroyable ce qu'il se passe .attention tes prete nenette ?
tu veux l'os ? tiens. je ne sais pas.ne me regarde pas comme ca. il est partie ou l'os ?
il est la ,il est juste là.tiens je te le mets ici.
mais il est passer ou ? regarde la croquette,elle est juste la.
tiens tu la veux ? haha.
la technique du chat.si y'a pas de croquette je 'men fous je te lécherai les doigts.
en conclusion ,je pense qu'on peux embrouiller un chien.
embrouiller un chat un peu.de base il s'en fous.
mais je suis pas sur de pouvoir les mentaliser.
je profite de cette vidéos pour dire un grand et un énorme merci a tout les abonnées qui vienne d'arriver.
vous êtes venue grace a la vidéos de pierre croce et vraiment pierre croce merci de m'avoir inviter a faire une vidéos avec toi.
j'espère que cette chaine en tout cas va vous plaire a vous tous .les nouveaux abonnées que vous allez vous trouvez bien chez moi .
y'a une vidéos par jour, tout les jours pendant 1 ans .si cette vidéos vous a plu vous pouvez laisser un pouce en l'air c'est pas une mentalisation.
si ca me mentalise moi. Prenez le temps de m'écrire dans les message, je lis tout les messages et j'essaie de repondre a un maximum
on viens de franchir le cap des 2.500 abonnées. j'avais promis qu'on ferai un apéro-live.
je vous en dis plus dans la vidéos de demain
je vous donne : la date,comment ca va s'organiser,comment on va faire ca.et on va se faire des mentalisation en live !!!
porter vous bien et rendez-vous demain dans le mentalvlog.CIAO
...outro...